hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com
so very quickly for those who are
watching my video for the first time let
me quickly introduce myself i've been
working as a professional trader for the
past six years in hong kong
and i've just decided to make some
youtube videos because guys i want to
pass
the knowledge i want to show you all the
different tools and techniques
that i like to use at work to make money
on the markets and in my videos i want
to show you how to do it yourself
so today i want to make a big update
guys on amc
and have a look uh on the longer term
let's get into it all right so
usually i start on the first time frame
in uh this video i want to start on the
daily time frame
and we are taking a step back guys and i
want to
show you what to me is actually playing
out
so i'm talking about the 35 level for a
long time
uh we're not there yet but we are going
there and
once we're gonna reach this let's see if
what might happen
so once again we're not there yet let me
quickly sum up the situation of what
happened this year
so we had this strong move up guys uh
from you know the
two area to 25
roughly developing in five waves all
right as usual moves up developing five
waves guys
then we had this correction abc three
waves
and then you know there was kind of a
question
are we gonna correct more or are we
gonna start a new
uh bull cycle and when i saw that here
we had those
five waves very clean one two three
four five and i'm not gonna zoom in but
if i do
each uh impulse here the third the fifth
and even the first
can be broken down in five waves too
which is actually telling us that we are
bullish all right so this is a very good
information you can use
from idiot wave theory is that if you
see a move
developing in five waves it's a motive
wave it's mean it means that the market
is gonna keep developing
probably in this direction so from there
i know that we are bullish and i know
that i'm expecting here
this correction that happened and here i
was trying you know to time
the rebound which was not easy we had
you know some kind of tricks
done by the market and it was
not that um clean
for me but anyways we still had uh
our uh signals that were quite clear
when they happened for example one of
the signals i used guys
to know that uh we are gonna
start having uh stronger moves
is this one the same i'm using on
gamestop guys uh all right on gamestop
we just broke it i didn't do the video
yet i'm gonna do it very soon
but we just broke this level all right
and here when we break this
you know in inside the first wave then
we have the second wave correct
put the corrective second wave and then
we know that we're having the third wave
that is going to be the most
impulsive one the strongest one with
strong associated volumes
all right so here we have our abc then
we have we are having
again after a one two three four five
abc we're gonna start again
one two three four five which is
actually the third wave of
this move that is happening here
so here i'm going to give you my
different scenarios right now we are in
the third wave of
this third wave and so the blue one
here and this is why when i did my video
last weekend guys i told you that you
know 12
would probably hold that this deep
because we had
some you know consideration here was
nothing and that we're expecting some
very strong
moves to come this week which we had
all right guys so now i might have one
or two days delay on this video but it
doesn't matter
what i'm not sure if we broke 17 or not
i'm not sure if we got
a bit rejected to the 15 level or not
it's not important guys you know what is
important is that
this wave is still developing and we are
only in the third wave
of this purple third wave so the
question is where
is it heading and for now it's too early
to answer this question
we first need to know where the third
wave is going to go
and then uh how the fifth wave is is
developing but for sure
we can expect something like this all
right so let's say we correct to 15
which is you know kind of my preferred
scenario
then we're gonna have a one two three
four five
maybe like this all right
so this is one of my scenarios
and either we go to 35 then it means
that we're going to correct maybe 25 or
even 17
and then do a few slaves that is going
to blow up everything
because 35 guys i remind you is our
all-time high
you know if i check on the weekly time
frame
you see guys 35 is not a random level is
the all-time high
and this is why i think we are first
getting there and probably
gonna break it if we arrive there with
enough strength
so let me come back here
so let's see let's see what we're having
guys um
you know the third wave might even break
the the 35 level itself you know this is
possible as well
but most likely it will be the maximum
of this
third wave and then let's see how deep
we correct but we know that we're gonna
have one move up
that's why we need some time i have told
you guys that
the 35 level would be reached this
summer i told you guys this you know a
long time ago
some of you you know were not sure i was
just saying this to make more views up
because i really believed and
i mean you know it's my analysis that is
telling me
what to tell you guys and for now what i
can tell you for sure
is that this third wave is gonna last
i think until the end of june and
and this is when we're gonna have more
information
if yes or no we're gonna break 35 uh
quickly or not
so i want to now show you
some very cool option strategies that
you can make
guys to actually benefit from this uh
whole
move up that is happening right now
so up
so i wanted to show you guys this
strategy so basically
very quickly uh let me remind you what
is a call option
is um is an option that is gonna pay you
the performance above a given level that
we call the strike so the formula is the
maximum between zero and
spot which is your spot level minus k
which is
the strike and by using call options
you can actually make some nice
option strategies so here the one i want
to show you guys
is what we call a butterfly so a
butterfly
is a payoff that has
this kind of shape where you have some
wings that's why we call it a butterfly
and a body
and to build this strategy so for
example you can do it like this
so you can buy the 2011 so
for example if i take the june maturity
which to me um
okay if i take the june maturity
and i take a butterfly that is 20 30 40
so let's we're gonna check the prices
very soon
so basically you buy for example 50 call
option of the 20 uh strike call
then you sell 100 options of the 30
strike call which is
here so
all right so if you just buy the call
option you're like this
then you sell here 100 so you're gonna
take the opposite direction on the
downside and then you want to cap your
loss you don't want to lose above
40. so you buy here 50 as well
and then you're like this you're having
a butterfly so now let's take the prices
of
those options so that we know the price
of this strategy so
i'm going to show you guys exactly how
you can do it yourself
you just go on yahoo finance
all right
you type amc
you go on the option chain which is here
guys
you take the june maturity which is very
liquid where you're gonna have
uh tight bid ask spreads
and you check the prices sorry
this is may
where is june
okay so we are now in the united states
so let's
let's check the prices so the 40 strike
is at 66.
so let's say we buy at 67 let's say we
cross the bid ask spread
so 67 30
we're gonna sell it at 91.
and the 20 is at 190
so the 20 is at 190 this one we're gonna
sell it
91 we said and we buy this one at 67.
all right and here i just compute my
premium
and bam all right so this would cost you
guys so maybe it's a bit
too much let's take 3 000 us dollars but
you can make
up to uh forty thousand
so let's say you do you know ten star
ten times less
up okay now it costs only four hundred
us dollars so it's the same strategies
and you can make up to 5
500. now the strategy i would make
myself i would go to the 25
you know i would here sell 7.5
okay so it's roughly the same basically
the number of
options you're having here must be zero
otherwise you're gonna have a problem
now and the 25 is probably cheaper
so the 25 costs
133 so once again i consider i cross the
bid ask spread so it's going to be
actually cheaper than this guys
because if you just put your order in
between the bid and the ask
you're going to see that you have a lot
of iceberg orders
which means some hidden orders at those
um between those levels
that you can be executed on
um so 1.27
all right so now for 120 us dollar so
this is you know
much more reasonable you can make up to
two thousand
uh 500 us dollars all right so i just i
want you to show you guys you know the
kind of strategies you can make how you
can check
um the premium the total prime you're
gonna pay
and the kind of uh payoff that you might
have
and i think that this is very
interesting to do on uh
stock like amc because you are selling
actually
um the upside call options you you see
here you're not only buying
you're buying the 25 but you're selling
the 30 all right so this is the reason
why
because the volatility is very high on
those strikes
that your option uh premium that the
premium of your total strategy
is not that big so guys that's it for me
i hope you enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to floor i see you
guys